In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for October 4th, on which we commemorate,
St. Ammon, the Egyptian, who died in peace.
Our Holy Father Ammon's parents died in his childhood.
He was brought up by an uncle who made him marry when he was still very young.
On the night of his wedding, as soon as he and his wife retired to the bridal chamber,
Ammon took up the holy scriptures and read the passage in the epistle to the Corinthians
where the Apostle speaks of the disadvantages of marriage because of all the troubles and
cares that come with it.
While virgins consecrated to the Lord can devote themselves without distraction to prayer
and to spiritual labor, both spouses took the following words literally.
From now on, let those who have wives be as though they had none, and those who deal with
the world as though they had no dealings with it.
They decided to remain in their virginity and to retire together to a desert place where
they could give themselves over to prayer and fasting.
They set out for the mountain of nitria some way from Alexandria and settled in a little
hut there, but living together as man and woman, they soon realized the inexperience of tempting
nature head on and of provoking the attacks of demons.
They parted company therefore each to live separately in Askeesies.
Ammon never used wine or oil but lived only on dry bread that he ate every two or three days.
His manner of life was pleasing to the Lord and a great many brethren who wanted to embrace
the monastic life soon came to join him.
When a new aspirant arrived, Ammon would immediately let him have his own cell with everything
in it, and the other brethren would secretly bring provisions to the newcomer or whatever
else might be useful.
This showed that fraternal love was first among the laws observed in this ever-growing brotherhood.
In a few years under the direction of Ammon, the desert of nitria was transformed into a
veritable city.
Some of the brethren now wanted to build their cells at a distance where they could live in
greater solitude, so when one day Saint Antony the Great came to visit him, Abba Ammon asked
his advice about the place to choose.
After taking a scanty meal together, they walked in the desert until sunset when they set
up across at the place they had reached so that those who wanted to could build their cells
there with the blessing of the two elders.
In this way Abba Antony said, the brethren coming from nitria after a meal at the ninth hour
to see those who are here will meet them at this moment.
And if those who leave here to go to nitria do the same, they will not lose their easy
hea, stillness.
This was how the desert of Kellia, the cells, came to be established almost twelve miles from
nitria, more than 600 monks were soon living there, each in his own cell.
Saint Ammon and Saint Antony were united in a deep spiritual friendship, when Abba Ammon
gave up his soul in peace to the Lord at nitria.
Antony far away on his mountain broke off from the conversation he was having with some monks,
and in ecstasy saw the soul of Ammon going up to heaven accompanied by the joyful hymns
of a multitude of angels.
Among other words inspired by the Holy Spirit, Saint Ammon said,
There with everyone as God bears with you through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord
Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.